[Applause]
Jason Jason boss it's like looking in a
mirror
Oh
it's all good have a seat have a seat
mc2 procedure finally reunited with your
wives to be but we now discover you know
everybody
you've met Regina Belle oh yes yes my
wife yes so many people we have six
degrees both in the DC Universe you know
yo yeah I know I know yeah look he's
here as well yeah yeah yeah this is this
is essentially what you would look like
if you were chopped off at the knees and
never went to the gym
[Laughter]
did you take this as a warning
annoyed you'd be on set anyway you stunt
doubles here
really
Jason Emily you have seen each other
since Game of Thrones every time I come
to England oh I just remembered so
because this goes out we're taping this
on a Thursday so this goes out tomorrow
night yes
so will you tomorrow night so when we
went to be here we'll be at my party
it will be us for party do you want to
I'd love to come as long as mystic and
swap clothes and I turn up first
[Applause]
Oh Ross is so
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh sure what is this coat is
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that might be dumb for this cat food in
the pocket what we thought you could you
could kind of fill in as your hostess
quizmaster because we've got some
questions this is a this is this is like
a friend's trivia oh oh oh she's gonna
win oh I don't know really I think you
you there's some free does some of you
all know if they don't know that I'm
sure the audience will know okay now to
hear the questions okay okay yes Judy no
cheating you're all complete yeah I know
the answer so I'd like you to put your
hand up if you know the answer yes yes
question what is Rachel wearing in her
first ever seen oh oh oh I can't answer
that a wedding dress
no wedding dress is the correct answer
[Applause]
question what is the next line after
this is about you being a brat wanting
what you can't have
Rhys can't have the only thing I can't
have is dairy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how did Rachel ruin the British trifle I
put beef in it beef in it at the bottom
i layered beef into the trifle you
didn't you didn't you put shepherd's pie
right Shepherd's pies not made with beef
it's made with lamb
[Applause]
expect a landlord to know that yes yes
[Music]
what song does Rachel sing to get her
daughter to stop crying baby got back is
the correct time for the audience and
for a bonus point Jennifer would you
like to sing the opening line of the
song I like big butts and I cannot lie
[Music]
[Applause]
theme song oh I could have told you that
do you want to say that so no one told
you that it's gonna be this way
[Music]
yes and this history for you to me Oh
the questions when Ross dated Rachel why
did you feel it was fine to sleep with
other women and I know it's because he
said we were on a break one of the
things I think that attracted you to
this film Robert is your home life
animals is it a farm you have we yeah we
wound up inheriting what was an old dog
and horse rescue oh I see up there in
Malibu way and then there was all these
empty stables and I I can't stand
negative space plus I'm a softie at
heart and there's a lot of rescue so are
these old rescues largely you've got
some llamas yes where's Madre and all
that is fuzzy on the left hairdressers
they were rescued from I needed sweaters
I think she's gone too short myself
she's the Alpha don't mess up her and
then you've got these lovely cows we do
those our Oreo cows I saw some in
Richmond and then they said they had
them up in Santa Barbara so give us a
couple belted Galloway's I believe
they're cold thank you you're welcome
[Applause]
Belted Galloway's oreo cows is cute pays
better
that's an Oreo cow but then you've got
some very ordinary things you've got
some chickens knocking around yes that's
a Burt up front the names on it
then now goats I feel are hard to keep
these days that looks like that's a
trigger and memo they are pygmy goats
and there are also brother lovers oh
yeah very modern it's perfect yeah
in the house not when they're active
okay this is this trigger mm oh this one
oh my god is our newest one and and his
sweet name is flash and that's a real
he's a real rescue he looks like he's
possessed by the devil I mean you have
one of the most relaxed cats I've ever
seen
that's montgomery named after your great
general that's amazing he's sort of more
of an ointment
yes he's heavily sedated there as a
younger person and his but you did sort
of channel the the seventies hair now
there's a picture you posted these
there's a picture of you this is I think
just nature I think this just nature
giving you got big seventies hair let's
see what happened to you Oh madam eight
never had orthodonture no braces it just
straightened out you grew into your self
I grew my head got bigger
giant teeth I never wore braces only
that
[Applause]
[Laughter]
grow into yourself yeah this is it I'm
getting short on just it's all it's all
going south presumably you are familiar
with Miriam's potty-mouthed because oh
are you because you're in high water but
did you actually work together yeah but
I don't know I've been told it was a
swear jar involved on set but I can't
remember that I don't you remember you
swearing a lot every I was probably
careful when it was you but when you
know with the other kids I didn't fall
I'm just talking backstage if that's
what you call that funny little girl
apparently it's 20 years since Harry
Potter came out there since we started
filming the first one and your balls
have dropped since
[Applause]
they're just weak kids they get it yes
[Applause]
but it's interesting because professor
sprout which you know you're in the
second film in the last film yeah I
should have been in all of them yes that
was a grave oversight I'm holding you
responsible
anyway it was wonderful to be in the two
that I was in and I'm very proud of it
but you do get recognized as professor
sprout I do
I mean I think I've changed since then
but people do recognize me and funnily
enough in Lithuania have you come just
to see professor sprout other films
called professors for after the Jeffie
remember I was mobbed in Lithuania maybe
because I was Jewish I don't know the
only one
my gosh you're amazing man I really
really enjoyed get out and everything
you're doing is fantastic I appreciate
you wonderful I made a song for you
Thanks
what you mean what do you mean oh it's
quick but it's the best I could do in a
short amount of time let's go
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well that was beautiful you got a thank
you so much I'm just out here
auditioning for everything does Matthew
know that he plays a special part in
your life uh no probably not
please I play a special part yeah can't
wait to hear this don't well I mean I my
wife and I sleep with you almost every
night yeah and every night there's an
app called calm and I have insomnia and
he has the most beautiful voice and I
turn it on and I just hear where hello
everybody it's me Matthew McConaughey
I'm gonna tell you a bedtime story and I
just do this oh ho my wife is from
Argentina she always goes like you have
them and talking again stop being in the
bed again
it's great though I decide cost me 80
bucks it was what worth out have you
know because I just sort of as you read
aside but you are actually putting
people to bed this is this is method
economy on the app tonight I hope to
send you after peaceful dreams with that
very thing in mind
what's your eyes closed and your breath
fall soft and slow as we begin our story
which just might rekindle that sense of
wonder
[Applause]
[Music]
you